[Music]
okay ready
raise your hand if you got a small dick
oh hell yeah dude the smallest in the
crew put your hand down steve you piece
of [ __ ] why you don't why did you have
your hat out i didn't realize everyone
was going to raise their hand that's all
you guys just kind of got me just
kidding
[Music]
i don't know what you're talking about i
think i got so shook because he raised
his hand next to you and made me feel
awkward you know the study i heard what
this is back in my favor
the a study i heard i love this yeah
this is good oh my italians
what's the study dude that the yeah
everyone's like oh your shoe size your
hand size whatever nah what is it schnoz
size no there's
over there no mine's like this though
it's black you get a wide cop so you got
to chode bro
hey this study is wrong
how did my back scratcher get there
hey that's contagious that's disgusting
what's wrong with this you're gonna get
covered dude that's cool you could keep
scratching ringworm 19 dude is this kobe
like no you could have it this is
disgusting it's over the shirt it's
yours that's a huge honor he never gives
it away you could use it
i bought five of them no nick's
vaccinate is good
but back to the small dick stuff hey
dude we gotta figure this out yeah i
don't have like a huge dick but i have a
huge right ball you should get that
checked out right that sounds like a
disease
hey did you see the um did you see the
world dick average thing what is it no
by country there's different sizes yeah
yeah it's crazy probably by nose i bet
the italians are killing dude nigeria
was packing bro you know how italian he
is
i um
i tried a vietnamese condom what does
that mean yeah what does that mean it
says though man when you put it on it
what was it like it's a red packet with
a gold star nice game
like they're black it's a communist
condom and they're all like that it's
government-issued all the same size wow
and when you open it it's all green
according to this canadians have bigger
dicks than americans if you want to
throw that out there but is it
canadian like a multicultural group of
people like what do you mean and they
all lie too right yeah dude canadians
are known for lying they're
untrustworthy yeah even their dollar
amounts all funky just want to say that
the average
erect penis length that is huge is in
ecuadorian all right as i move on that
is really close to argentina i don't
know about the italians but us
argentinians are
how big are those fellas 6.93
that would be so weird if like someone
tall like steve had an average dick it
would actually look small they would
because proportion wise i've seen tall
guys with little ones i saw a big ass
dude like a buff big guy with like a
baby stick and i was laughing so hard i
think that happens a lot that's about
right i stopped training legs like three
years ago because it just starts to make
it look yeah yeah yeah yeah that's smart
i had really big quads and i was like
nah no more squats oh [ __ ] i see a lot
of dicks at the korean spa so you're
saying that's the only reason why i
think my dick's big because my quads are
like chicken legs oh i'm gonna keep them
like that yeah maybe all right
so activists hold a small dong march to
end shaming of tiny penises oh shut the
[ __ ] up dude when you fight for it it
makes it even funnier
i'm proud of my spawn penis yeah do my
small penis like so are they it's part
of who i am
they are too but i'm not gonna get mad
at other people for shaming me you know
no no they're not even mad it's false
confidence proud of you yours is real
connor because like i'm embracing on
celebrating it like no don't shame me
don't you hug each other harder if you
have to have a parade about how small
like you're proud that your dick is
small you're insecurity hug each other
harder you little [ __ ]
i don't get it like you say we're all
insecure why do you say everybody who
throws the parade is insecure kind of i
mean dude have a cry circle while you're
at it pal not all parades not all
parades are good but not all parades are
created equal most parades are wack
let's be real i'm not a parade guy like
the rose parade that [ __ ] that's just
pretty wack it's cool but like cooper
yeah it used to be cool the thanksgiving
day parade is the most insecure thing
i've ever seen i don't think the
holidays parades are [ __ ] here about
being off no it's more insecure than
macy's
oh the macy's one what the [ __ ] how are
you gonna have a store parade fake
there's a bunch of floats nordstroms
ain't doing that [ __ ] yeah they don't
need to
because everyone's going there
nordstrom's baby
fireworks
[ __ ] tj maxx never heard of their
partner
they got a max for a reason
tj moon
does the parade for sure every year is
the tj min parade we need a good old
like a old school military parade with
[ __ ] tanks why don't we do it like
those dictator countries i love it i
want the u.s military yeah i want them
to come out of [ __ ] here's the
marines the navy you guys see the north
korean like martial arts demo that they
did it's lit bro dude
that was one of the coolest [ __ ]
things i've ever seen see they they
always got the dope in the wrong country
let's just move to north korea i want a
[ __ ] warhead to be like shown they
didn't even show warheads bro it was
just guys like old-school like shaolin
monk style like test of strength where
guys are breaking bats on their back wow
and it's like okay why are we showing
this dude you know what they should do
line up the streets with people
and then have commentators about how the
world's first ninja parade and then just
like empty streets
because they're ninjas yeah but then
you're commenting about the ninjas about
the different groups of ninjas
that's the shadow
clan you hear that wind
ten of them just passed by yeah
that's the wind clan that's the shaolin
group yeah
yeah bro dozens of men have hit the
streets for a small dong march seeking
the end to so-called shame associated
with having and
but what is the criteria because what if
someone has body dysphoria and they
believe they got a small ass dick even
though they got a big [ __ ] dick and
then they're walking the parade and
they're like hey get the [ __ ] out of
here this ain't for you and they're like
what i'm i identify as a small dick i
don't know if they're walking with their
penis sizes out but they do that's a
great thing
i uh i don't think if you have a small
dick you can call it a dong can i ask
this what is it you gotta call it a date
it's just a ding yeah yeah
though everybody understands it's a
small penis but if they just call it a
ding parade what about a small penis i
have a question that's just derogatory
can guys with big dicks walk with the
small dick guys in solidarity no get the
[ __ ] out of here bro you know
no i support you guys man what the [ __ ]
no i think it's cool dude
i'm proud of you brother solidarity
because that's like volunteering that's
like when straight people were in the
gay pride place i'm always like get the
[ __ ] out of there i thought it's their
thing dude
yeah
you're in solidarity but usually they're
like no we love the support right so
they're trying to get brownie points so
if i'm a small dog or just a regular
ding regular ding then i'm gonna want as
many big dicks around me as possible to
show that we are all here together get
the [ __ ] out of here dude steve you
can't march with us get the [ __ ] out of
here you too mike get out of here no i'm
authentic guys i'm authentic according
to this article dorian it's not the size
of the protest it's what you do with it
that's funny these guys are funny dude
this took place last saturday in dtla
organized by two youtube stars chad and
jt oh this sounds like a joke man come
on it took us seven minutes i know
we're getting slow guys i mean maybe it
started as a joke but dozens of guys
showed all penises showed up you know
why it's because with this climate
though
there's so much crazy [ __ ] that happens
in this climate that that is serious you
don't know what the [ __ ] is a joke
anymore especially in l.a bro but also
don't have a parade for you having a
small dick dude yeah do anything else
dude there's men's rights parades yeah
you they're losers too get out of here
all of you guys big dick guys had a
parade everyone would be like those guys
have small dicks
wait they're naked or not
they're not walking around naked i hope
they are if that was in san francisco
they'd be naked yeah i think they were
in love with that yeah it's too cold in
l.a right now yeah that's freezing
that's something
everyone's small california people it's
like 70 degrees it's [ __ ] freezing
yeah you don't think they're all
fighting for oh damn it you don't think
they're all fighting for something
really just virtuous and it's like four
people in the parade i knew it there's
women there look at this kind of a big
dick
wait i used to take my dogs there to
take a [ __ ] oh yeah this girl's cracking
up it's in solidarity with shrimp dicks
that's hilarious
right yeah you can't say shrimp it can
be serious yeah you can't do that that's
not a metaphor that's serious you don't
think she's she's in support
you don't think she actually loves going
home it's sucking small dick yeah it's
funny all the girls showed up and then
bang a single one of them this [ __ ]
exactly yeah okay so like what i love
what this makes fun of
is this makes fun of men out there who
want to be respected and treated but
they go by it this way which in turns it
turns around without like you don't have
confidence you you actually sound like a
little [ __ ] if you've ever winded a
woman involved they won't [ __ ] you
you're so [ __ ] lame
oh god it's it's so embarrassing yeah i
i dude
when i think about it it's so
embarrassing it must be easy for you to
say with your big old dick dude
i don't have a big dick my wife measures
from the back of my [ __ ] that's why
everyone thinks
34 inches see [ __ ] how come they
didn't teach me to make you get from the
gooch yeah dude i'll be like a whole
three inches dude that'd be pretty cool
man
you shouldn't have to do that if you got
a big dick guys
i want to measure like that i mean i
want respect at the end of the day i
think i think most of the comments on uh
on the media that's going around on this
is cracking up about the situation uh
talking about
anybody will protest anything in l.a
nowadays you know what the trick is you
just never let your partner look at your
penis that's it that's what i do that's
what kind of trick is that yeah just
never let him or you just stretch it
before you measure it yeah dude you just
hold the tip and you pull it like this
that's the technique it's like whoa look
how long it is now yeah it's skinnier
you guys wouldn't know about that
for that to work i don't know the
stretch you're supposed to measure it
soft right that's how you know
that's why i'm only 10 inches good for
you man hey these italians
i knew you weren't big i knew it
[Laughter]
ecuador
[Music]
you